it's great to welcome back to the
program Alex maja sure who's the
co-founder of Bros for America a
progressive advocacy organization he's
also a political writer and commentator
for the Huffington Post well Alex
we now have indictment number four and
guilty plea number two in this robert
muller invasion when do we trust
I'm sorry welcome Bueller we trust in
New York yes four indictments two guilty
pleas do you feel vindicated in some way
I mean is this do you think we're
getting close to the end is this only
the beginning I mean I think we're
seeing a Muller approaching the endgame
here I think we're I mean you've gone
basically as high up as you can get
within that campaign other than the Vice
President and I think that the evidence
is very clear that if if Michael Flynn
is guilty then so is Mike Pence because
Mike Pence knew and and I think that
it's almost unfathomable
unfathomable to suggest that the
president himself was not aware of all
of this going on around him and you know
their email is now on point as you know
as you have seen report on that earth
that are showing that this campaign was
aware of this is this is a active
efforts to conspire with a foreign
hostile power to influence an American
election well that may be we may
ultimately see charges related to that
but to play devil's advocate what some
on the writer and saying is yes there
there have been indictments
but the indictments don't relate
directly to actions taken that actually
concerned the Trump campaign and the
attempt to become president of the
United States that you're talking about
lies about things that took place you're
talking about in the case of Paul man
afford financial crimes that predated
his involvement in the Trump
administration by and large what about
people who point that out I don't know
that I don't know that Muller would have
made a deal with Mike Flynn if you
weren't aiming right for the top and if
you weren't aiming for the jugular on in
terms of the elections interference but
we'll see I mean you could very well be
right it could just be this sort of
tinge
issues but I think that this is a sign
that Muller is going straight for the
for the very head honcho otherwise I
don't think you were to cut a deal with
Mike Flynn what about you that's that's
been my analysis which is that if you're
pointing out that Michael Flynn was
charged with this one thing only that
there this is a very early indictment
watergate took years and we're basically
eight weeks in and we have four
indictments i can't imagine that the
indictment against flynn would come so
early if it weren't a calculated move to
use flynn to go higher i mean that
that's been my reaction i agree with you
and i think you know the the watergate
stuff happened in a time where there was
no one for me isn't maybe didn't have
any transference of information and now
we have the emails and it's digital and
i think it's much this is gonna move
much faster now it's picky yeah speed in
a exponential rate so I'm looking
forward I think maybe Donald Trump will
getting indicted by the end of the month
no I think I don't know if you're
kidding around but I don't know that
Trump will get indicted at all you know
you don't think so no I go down Alex I
think if Trump goes down it's going to
be through a resignation or impeachment
maybe I think if he goes down it's gonna
be resignation
well impeachment is definitely not gonna
happen not with this huh I mean look
what we just saw the Republican Senate
do they just you know on Friday night
with the tax bill they are completely
out of control and they're totally not
going to they're not going to impeach
this president so the only chance I
think of impeachment is if Democrats are
able to take back the house in 2018
which will be another year and and that
will be I think I think it's doable
given the climate sort of sort of the
political climate right now and
especially what happened in Virginia and
New Jersey but I think you're probably
right I think he would he would sooner
resign than to to suffer the indignity
of a indictment but we'll see we'll see
it's moving pretty quickly I think
I mean we'd not have you heard the
stories now about you know uh uh you
know his son-in-law
his name is skater the moment but you
know this is going tera Kushner Goodall
Kushner you know why I don't know his
name is
never heard the guy speech hey let me
ask you this Alex what do you make of
the contingent of the left that even as
of this morning continues to insist that
there is no Russia story that it's a
distraction that it's an attempt to sort
of try to prop up Hillary Clinton as
having been a better candidate than some
believe she was what what where are you
on your analysis of the faction of the
left that is saying there's no Russia
story um I find it problematic I find it
problematic because a if we do not
acknowledge interferences with our free
and fair elections the very cornerstone
of our American democracy that very the
most essential part of a democracy is
the free fair elections if we do not
acknowledge that this interference
occurred we are just allowing it to
continue and we're allowing the culture
we're creating a culture what we allow
we encourage and we already have signs
that Russia is already meddling I mean
they're already the troll farm is alive
and well I am certain that I did deal
with Russian trolls daily on Twitter at
Aleks maja sure if anyone wants to
follow me but there's there's a lot of
evidence to show that it's still going
on so if we don't address this problem
it's going to be a problem that
continues and that's that's very very
frightening we can't have a foreign
hostile power dictating our elections
and now we have evidence that a hundred
and twenty six million Facebook users
were subjected to Russian ads we've got
evidence that that these Facebook groups
were like fake racialized activist
groups that were that were just sort of
trying to influence opinion and cause
racial discord this is a massive effort
that involved a year or more of many
many Russian operatives sitting in a
Russian bunker in at the Kremlin you
know dropping fake news onto the
Facebook pages of of people in the
essential swing states Wisconsin
Michigan and Pennsylvania and how did
they know to drop that information there
well it's because they were colluding
with the Trump campaign and because they
were stealing voter dadoes we have
evidence now that suggests that much so
what Alex Wow what is the interest
what's the interest of some on the left
in
nying the russia story why why why was
it sometimes they would seek to deny in
your mind I think that there is a
there's the I think the Bernie Sanders
and Hillary Clinton war that we have
seen in terms of the supporters the two
factions it is ongoing and is continuing
today I was at a Hillary Clinton book
signing on Friday and there were Bernie
Sanders supporters there protesting her
protesting a book signing I was pretty
flabbergasted by that and I went out and
I asked them I interviewed a few of them
just to see what was going on you know I
told them you know she's not running for
anything he she's she's a former
presidential candidate right now there's
a tax bill going up before the Senate
maybe you should direct your attention
towards that I think that they are very
hell-bent on on having justice for what
they view as a 2016 Democratic primary
that was stolen from them which is
factually incorrect well it's actually
incorrect I don't know I mean I'm not
sure where you are on that issue but I
mean at least from my perspective the
DNC was not even close to a fair arbiter
of that primary whatsoever and and I
don't you know to say stolen you need
sort of to definitively know that for
sure Bernie Sanders would have otherwise
won it's very hard to prove something
that didn't happen but for me that the
problem is of course that being said it
doesn't have any bearing on what Russia
may or may not have done that's why I'm
concerned of course you're absolutely
right but I will just point out that
Hillary Clinton did win the Democratic
primary by four million votes which is a
veritable landslide four million votes
in a thousand delegates which is a vast
mad landslide in Democratic primaries in
terms of the general election she won
that race by three million votes and
then lost in the electoral college so
it's it is apples and oranges okay but
hold on a sec whoa let's let's see if we
can break this apart a little bit yes
all right the numbers you cited are all
correct I don't know what the general
election results have to do with the
primary but I'm sure that you as a
political analyst know that in a primary
the final numbers don't reflect the
paths that could have been
taken because once it becomes clear that
one candidate is going to be the winner
supporters just fall off of whoever
candidate number two is I don't know
that looking at the final numbers tells
us that early on had the DNC not already
been been clearly decided that they were
supporting Hillary Clinton that it
wouldn't have been different from the
start I don't think that that's that we
can really say that well I'm so I I
agree with you and disagree but of
course this this debate is exactly why
it answers your question I think that
this is this debate is what is still
wrangling many of the supporters who are
upset about the primary of 2016 and I
think it's causing some discord yeah
wrinkling me right I mean I'm I'm I'm
telling you I don't know if yours but I
said on the I don't agree on the primary
analysis but I'm completely on board
with you about the problem it's saying
hey Russia doesn't exist of course of
course I view you as one of the one of
the with it ones but it's I think when
you talk about that faction of the left
that is upset of not upset about Russia
yeah I think that that's probably
motivated by a sort of a willful apathy
or a willful sort of ignorance because
they don't they don't want to have to
concede that she won no one wants to
concede that Hillary Clinton won the
Democrat the elect a 2016 election and
it's I understand will apply we are very
it is a very troubling thing it's it's a
thing of conspiracy theorists and you
know crackpots but you know it's that is
it's troubling and and it's hard for us
as a society to to accept things that
are outside of this our sort of normal
day-to-day flow it disrupts what we
understand so you know hopefully we get
some answers some finite some final
answers about this but yeah I think that
the anything anything to keep a victory
for Hillary Clinton out of the lips of
people is what's motivating some real
quick Alex in the limited time we have
left
what was
beef you had with Tucker Carlson when
you first run and did you want to have
any is there any follow-up to that that
you wanted to send a message to him or
anything
Tucker Carlson suggested that I was a
crackpot for merely stating that the
Department of Justice was investigating
the Russian interference with the with
the election and uh all I gotta say is
where's my gift basket Tucker I want an
apology and I want it now
all right Alex Mohajir co-founder of
Bros for America you can follow his
writing on the Huffington Post Alex
thank you we're gonna continue following
the investigation as we have been you're
doing great work David